Nó Ngay mùa mùa tháng bẩy, là thời khác thêm liên và trong đại của sinh tộc khi bá mê tư tình, thành phố trong cả nước chính thức đồng là bận hành bộ máy chính quyền địa phương 2 cấp.
Sự kiện đang giấu một chình thị hành chính mới của nước cộng hoa giả hội chủ hiếp Việt Nam với tầm vóc chính lực đặc biệt lớn lọc.
Được thiết kế cho cả hệ tại và tương lai nhằm kiến tạo mua hình khung dàn phát triển mới lâu dài và bên bứng.
Bây giờ tổ chức lại để giới hành chính, bất hành mua hình chính quyền địa phương mới không chỉ là sự kiện về mặt hành chính.
Mà là bước chuyển mình chiến lực, là đoài hỏi tất yêu hệ quan của nhân dân và đất nước trong hành chính xây dự những vùng động lực phát triển của quốc gia và khu vực.
Sự đang với hết bỏng Việt Nam hùng cường và năm 2019.
Môi những chiến quyền địa phương 2 cấp không chỉ cắt bỏ cấp chúng dân,
mà điều quan trọng hơn là tổ chức lại không dàn cho phát triển bên bứng.
Để chiến quyền vân dân, sát dân, bây dân, phục vũ nhân dân được tốt hơn để mọi lợi thuộc về nhân dân.
Chúng an cũng vấn đình gió thử mỗi thử của mình và chào quyền chủ động nhiều hơn cho chính quyền địa phương để mỗi nơi năng động,
sát tạo và chiến vụ ở thực hiện.
Không dàn và chiến mới này được kiến tạo dự trên tầm giền dài hạn,
hương đề sự và chiến đồng bộ, bên vững và khó học,
sau đây mới là bước đi tên phòng.
Vì tinh gọi tổ chức bộ mại của hệ thống chính xị,
sắp sẽ lại đơn vị hành chính các cấp cũng thác động,
an người mừng đến tư tưởng mộ bộ phận cánh bộ,
đảng viên, công chức, viên chức, người lao động.
Tâm lý, vẫn đầy khắp biệt về văn hóa,
phong tục tập quán, tên gọi quên thuộc hình thành tự lâu đời của nhân dân mỗi địa phương.
Điều đó đoài hỏi sự công miền, đồng thuận và quyết tâm chính trị rất cao và đặc biệt là sự hi sình lợi ít cá nhân.
Nếu thiếu đàn kết thống nhất thì quả chính thực hiện sẽ sế phát sinh vướng mắc, bất cập.
Cơ lúc nào hết, giờ đây, phải có lợi ít quốc gia là trên hết,
phải đặt tự lai phát sinh của tổ quốc làm được điều tối thượng.
Tương duy và nhận tức đó đoài hỏi mỗi cán mộ,
đảng viên mỗi tổ chức cơ quan, địa phương,
đơn vị phải vượt lên trên những lợi ít quốc mộ tâm nhìn hạn hệ.
Những nước nghĩ, thoại quên, tập quán của có thể là đúng,
là hợp lý trong quả hữ, như này có thể sẽ không còn đáp ứng được đoài hỏi của thời đại và yêu cầu phát sinh.
Đến thời điểm này, đối ngũ chúng ta đã chính tề,
hàng lối đạng hành án, cả rất to cùng hành quân vườn tới tương lai dực dưới của đất nước.
Bí hành phút của nhân dân, bí một phía nằm phát sinh, thình vượng vũn bệnh.